- What's up, hey, how's it going?
Are you free this weekend?
Cause I got no friends,
but I got some great plans ahead for us.
Let's go.
Brunch, okay, first of all,
who doesn't love a good meal with friends?
Plus, brunch means that
you can eat breakfast
while still sleeping in.
Plus, who doesn't love a
good mimosa, am I right?
You know what?
It's time to treat yourself!
Go to the mall and buy a
nice outfit just for you.
Why?
Because you deserve it.
Who says sleepovers are just for kids?
Not me.
Grab a couple of your closest friends,
and have a fun night inside.
Look at how much fun they're having!
Look at them!
Aw, look at them, they look so cute.
I love to sing, even though I can't.
But it doesn't matter,
because you can go out
and sing with other people
who are bad at singing,
and everybody wins.
Feeling a little bit
adventurous this weekend?
Hiking can be the perfect trip for you,
especially after a long, stressful week.
Think about all the cool Instagram photos
that you can take with nature.
So, there we go.
All of our plans for the weekend are set.
We're gonna hang out,
we're gonna hang out!
Let's go.
I'm dancing, I'm dancing, I'm dancing,
I'll pick you up, see ya.